dailymail.com i'm not sure
uh troy is that a [ __ ] publication
in the uk uh
ish it's there's some [ __ ] but they
also have some serious stories as well
that's all of them that's all okay so
apparently they've got this
study here from scientists it says could
a bad marriage kill you
unsatisfactory relationships are as bad
for you as smoking
say scientists researchers studied 30
years of health and death data on 10 000
men in israel
the men were in their 40s when they
first started gathering the data in the
1960s there's a lot of data then
if married the men were asked to rate
their marriages on a scale of one to
four
one on the scale was very satisfied with
their marriage and four was unsatisfied
there was a clear link between an
unhappy marriage and increased
death rates i'm not surprised uh the
primary
sorry this primarily applied to the case
of stroke but was
so bad a bad long-term relationship can
cause a stroke for you fellas
but it was found in all premature deaths
um
the studies linked and the article is
linked in the um description of the
video if you guys want to read it we're
not going to read it all but
just to kind of like you know get the
ball rolling on this
this is something i've known for a while
i don't know about
you guys what are your thoughts on that
notion so you have the old
adage of uh married men live longer but
that's really
because they become more docile and take
less risks and don't really live
so not only yeah that's the question
does marriage kill guys faster unhappy
marriages kill guys faster but like
what's the point of living longer or
living at all if you're that miserable
in that marriage
anyways how long were you married for
john seven and a half years
yeah for me it was like two and a half
or three years before i was like i gotta
get out of this this is not good for me
on a long term basis like i
i can't do this for the rest of my life
and i just had this like
[ __ ] like voice that was like dude
you gotta go um
so i heard that voice not in my marriage
but like when i was at the bpd girl
well i was talking to john you know
beforehand before you guys kind of
pulled into the green room
you know waiting area and i kind of went
through this exercise a few years ago
where i looked through
my friends list on facebook and i've got
a very small friends list and i know
pretty much most of them like on an
intimate basis like they're not distant
or people that i've never met
and i think it was something like 1 in
that i counted that was in an actual
happy
long-term relationship or a marriage the
rest of them were either pretending or
miserable
yeah right i wouldn't be surprised yeah
dude
it's similar when you think about it oh
sorry troy is just saying in the navy
used to be bad it was
for the senior enlisted they used to
like swap notes on who had more divorces
the winner
was my boss at five by the way it was a
very quebec thing to do
but let me ask you this five times dude
five times
and every single one was horrible
apparently
you have to be
like four or five marriages too like
he's been married a few times too right
yeah but just imagine that though like
guys would rather slowly be
belittled to death than take their own
health like you say too rich how people
don't want to eat to be healthy or
take testosterone if you need to take it
they'd rather sit in a marriage and have
her like slowly kill him with pie and
nagging
than to do something about it well
speaking of pie and nagging it's funny
because i'm in a
a trt group on facebook and i don't
really participate on more of fly on the
wall but there's a lot of women in there
and it always boggles me i mean i'm not
surprised but
it always happens where women will chime
in and be like my husband's on trt he's
got a limp dick or he's got this story
and it's like
the wife is in there trying to run the
dude's life when it's his life
and it's his endocrine system and it's
his hormone panel that matters
and she's in there like probably nagging
the guy on the side and
then sharing all of his laundry with all
the other guys in the group and it's
like
there's certain places where women
should not participate
sounds like married man sex life forums
doesn't it ryan
rest in peace so they're going in this
apparent to karen for the
for the husbands then they're saying oh
my my guy needs to sort himself out
yeah and dude if you click on their uh
profile and you look at them
you know you look at the pictures like
well i can tell you why he's probably
not getting hard
[Laughter]
no amount of testosterone is going to
change anything he has no problem
getting hard he's just jerking off
try the holistic approach first before
you start putting chemicals in here
[Laughter]
anyway so chemical you guys have all
done some consults you know like
on a one-on-one basis i know you've
dealt with guys going through the
divorce machine and long-term
relationships
what's your general view on this notion
in this scientific study that
that you know essentially concludes if
you're in a shitty long-term
relationship you're going to die younger
i'll um i'll go real quick i i counsel
guys
i have as you know one of them is robert
kiyosaki
um but i i've counseled guys who are
anywhere between like
60 and 75-ish i think 75 is probably the
oldest that i've
ever counseled in fact when i first got
into peer counseling it was usually guys
between 45 and 65.
um back when i was studying um
and uh yeah a lot of them complain about
the same thing that they do right now
and i think that a lot of guys i think
most of the sort of dissatisfaction
in their marriage when they get into the
later years is due to like blue pill
conditioning
and they cling to it and it's always
worked for them or they don't know any
other thing in fact that's one of the
reasons why like my book is so
um i guess jarring to these guys lives
because they
realize that where they're at in life
and the woman that they're with and what
they've been dealing with for like
in some cases like 20 or 30 years
um is a result of their not knowing the
game right they're not they're being
you know kind of plugged into all this
and so they get really they tend to get
really hostile
in the beginning and then they're like
then they get like kind of despondent
and they go through like you know the
stages of
unplugging and everything but it's
tougher for guys who are older
because they've already made their bed
and they have to lie in it
and i think a lot of these guys feel
like they can never get out of it so
i think that that sort of um that
feeling of being trapped
and trapped because most of the guys
when i when i encounter them the first
thing is they don't want to leave their
wives they just want their wives to bang
them again
that's all they want pretty much they
love their wives they're in love with
them
but they can't live with them because
they're like they're addicted to
pornography because you know she won't
bang him or
um you know she's it's a constant
nagging it's a constant uh and i've i
talked about this with uh with pat
campbell back in the day is that
you know nagging is really sort of a low
level [ __ ] test
for um for married couples because
when when when [ __ ] tests happen and
you're single
it's usually like she's trying to test
you for quality
whereas when you're married and you get
[ __ ] tests
it's usually because she's like is this
guy the best i can do is he really is he
like i i need security i need i need
this guy to actually do so
mow the lawn washadasha's do the you
know like she
she brow beats him and hen pecks him all
the time to get him to do like chores
and stuff like that
and it's usually like you should have
thought of that sooner and it's like you
you're not good enough blah blah blah
and so it's this constant qualification
so she nags him and the nagging is
usually just sort of qualification and
his qualification is always this
how can i make her happy how can because
if i could make her happy then she'd
start having sex with me again and we
can get back to where we were before i
love her i don't want to break up with
her
but i want it to be better and so they
get into this
cycle of this constant like it's it's uh
in some cases it's almost like ptsd
because they're like very
you know they're walking on eggshells
all the time they're like how can i make
her happy
i'll buy her this i'll take her here uh
i'll make her life as easy as possible
and the first thing that i think was
that uh luke said one day
uh he said uh the surest way to make a
woman miserable
is to give her everything she's ever
asked for that she wants
and that's what these guys try to do and
if you're doing that constantly yeah
you're going to live a [ __ ]
life and you're going to have
hypertension and you're going to
probably have what is it a cortisol
up right i mean you're not going to
sleep well um and so and if you try to
change anything
that's when she's like well why do you
feel like you got to go to the gym now
is there girls there blah blah blah you
know it's this constant
you know where they are and yeah and
that's
it's like having your uh a jail warden
there all the time
sure yeah that you're gonna live an
unhealthy life
and nine times out of ten is because a
guy is still living
in this idea that he has to qualify he
has to it's transactional sex
if i just pay for this if i get a bigger
house if i make it more comfortable
once she gets here and then and then
they get to menopause
it goes to hell after that so i i that
that's number one number two is this is
i think that um
i think when we talk about like what's
happy and what's not happy
that's really kind of like a container
word ryan i think it's like whatever it
is that you seem to think is is going
like these guys will probably say that
they're
they're they're happy as can be it's
just that they want certain aspects of
their relationship to be better
but they don't realize that they could
like once they get out of that
relationship and this is the first thing
that happens is when i deal with a guy
who is married and then he gets divorced
and then he learns
just even the the smallest amount of
when he starts getting laid
he's like what the [ __ ] was i doing why
was i with
[ __ ] for two for 30 years i can get
with girls who are like 20 years younger
than me now
and they're having the sex that they
wanted to they're getting in a little
bit better shape you know they're caring
about themselves a little bit more
and it's like i think it was sterling
cooper says you know your testosterone
level will
will rise when you get married this is a
clinical fact when you get married
where you get into a long-term
relationship your testosterone levels
will drop
when you get out of it when you like are
divorced
men's testosterone levels go back up
that is not a good
that's a feature not a bug okay what
happens because
for a reason so when these guys get out
and they're like
why was i wasting 20 years of my life in
this marriage
when i could have been banging young
hotties this whole time and caring about
me and making me my mental point of
origin
then they start kicking themselves and
they ask because they're like what was i
thinking
that's another level of like despondency
and nihilism that you have to deal with
you